ils sont à l'origine du projet les
jeunes de maurepas on rêvait d'un
nouveau skatepark
il a été inauguré vendredi de juin
dernier l'ancien était très vieillissant
et même dangereux ce que j'ai du le le
faire fermer puisqu'il avait des plaques
métalliques qui se soulever et donc
après ça a été soumis au vote des morts
patients et plus de 200 votes se sont
prononcés sur ce projet et donc voilà
après on a engagé d un groupe de travail
que j'ai souhaité participatif proposé
lors d'un projet participatif et d'un
budget de moins de cent mille euros
la structure est en béton un matériau
pérenne une piste de 72 mètres de long
une dizaine d'éléments pour rêver ça
fait longtemps qu'on attend ça et puis
c'est au rendez vous ça ça glisse bien
ça roule bien
on a tout ce qu'il faut on est content
c'est pour attendu depuis les années du
béton parce que tu vois le le bouton
qu'on a là bas c'est pas tip top
donc c'est cool qui en investissement
pour pour le skate park dès son
inauguration le skate park était pris
d'assaut le maire lui-même n'a pas pu
résister